When we rationalize this fraction, we'll get 4 root 35 plus 2 root 15. Great
effort if you found it. We start by multiplying the numerator and denominator
by the conjugate of this expression. The conjugate of 2 root 5 minus root 7 is
2 root 5 plus root 7. We multiply 26 to each of these terms to get 52 root 5
plus 26 root 7. For the denominator, we use our difference of squares to do a
squared minus b squared. We can't simplify or combine terms in the numerator,
since this is root 5 and this is root 7. So we just list the numerator here
again, and then we simplify the denominator. 2 squared is 4, and the root of 5
squared is 5. We have our subtraction sign and then we have the square of root
7, which is just 7. We simplify our denominator to get 13, and then divide it
into each of the terms. 15 divided by 13 is 4, and 26 divided by 13 is 2.
Another way to think about it, is we're really factoring a 13 from the 52 root
5, and the 26 root 7. If we factor our 13 out, we'll be left with 4 root 5,
plus 2 root 7. This allows us to simplify the factor of 13 that appears in the
numerator, and denominator. This simplifies to 1. So we're left with this for a
fraction, and anything divided by 1, is simply itself. So we can write our
answer like this.